vous avez eu dans votre vie des hauts et
des bas comme tout le monde et on va
faire une interview
[Musique]
j'arrive
ce que vous préférez en vous
ma part ma chance la chance que j'ai
ouais c'est pas en moi c'est je suis né
sur une chose une bonne étoile avait une
chance folle toute ma vie vous voyez pas
été plus heureux si vous aviez vécu au
caire finalement avec faten hamama avant
d'être une star cairote en étant une
star égyptienne c'est possible je ne le
saurai jamais je ne ferai jamais ce qui
serait arrivé si on m'avait pas pris
pour lawrence d'arabie il est fort
possible que j'aurais été plus heureux
dans ma vie oui parce que vous soyez
aussi peut-être pas comme ça dans une
chambre d'hôte heures il dit gosse
bretagne par un patriarche amis patriat
alors c'est
ce que vous haïssez en vous
je n'ai rien en moi parce que quand je
vais quelque chose si je l'aï c'est
quelque chose en moins je ferai de tous
pour corriger cette chose que je vais y
avait plus beaucoup de fric à c'était en
66 fric j'ai gagné un million $ au
casino parce que j'étais avec une
gt dans le nord de l'italie il y avait
une starlette qui était assise à côté de
moi qui étais très très bien et on est
allé à discothèque on a flirté tout puis
jeudi de monter avec moi chez elle
voulait bien prendre un verre dans ma
chambre m'a dit non j'étais fou de rage
mais vu pas mal je suis allée au casino
et j'ai joué le numéro que je ne joue
jamais c'est à dire le 29 à la roulette
et ses sorties 4 x 2 from exclusion
dévaliser la banque oui
c'est alors le lendemain j'ai acheté
toutes les fleurs d'interflora
et j'ai envoyé un camion parce que tu es
allé à rome j'ai envoyé un camion de
fleurs à cette jeune dame qui était dans
north tout à fait 2,5 tonnes 5 tonnes de
fleurs christian que les autres non elle
est devenue floris du retour
du brésil et inélégamment une carte qui
disait vous auriez été le coup le plus
cher de ma vie
le plus grosses pertes c'est quand vous
êtes obligés de vendre ou de votre
appartement oui j'ai ouï j'ai aussi
c'était dans ces heures d'avancé comme
là c'était tout l'argent que je
possédais au monde
d'abord en banque le plus grand moment
de votre vie
difficile le plus grand moment je sais
peut-être chez pas la naissance de mon
fils - probablement
j'adore mon fils je suis vraiment aux
fanatiques de mon fils et la mnef aussi
le pire moment
le pêcheur s'est passé là c'est tous les
moments de déchéance physique quand
quand on est malade et que les nerfs
doivent s'occuper de vous et vous
accompagne et à la salle de bain c'est
des moments atroces j'étais malade
boucher j'ai eu et j'ai fait un pontage
et urinant chez changer une hanche c'est
une prothèse j'ai une prothèse vous
suivez plus là non je suis même pas à
manger arrêté au test est faux
non j'ai eu un miracle pour arrêter de
fumer parce que je fumais 100 cigarettes
par jour et un jour j'ai eu mal à la
poitrine et j'ai compris que cette
écriture de cardiaque alors comme je ne
savais pas qu'il parlait j'ai regardé le
plafond et je lui ai parlé j'ai dit
écoute je n'ai jamais parlé avant je te
dire maintenant si tu me fais vivre
jusqu'à demain matin j'arrête de fumer
bon et puis j'ai arrêté puis j'ai repris
une cigarette pour allumer j'ai eu un
choc électrique
et quand les mises dans ma bouche j'ai
été très malade j'ai vomi j'ai eu des
nausées terrible et depuis je n'ai plus
pu toucher une cigarette vous arrivez
alors cahiers et je lui ai plus jamais
parler j'attends
cette ancienne émission l'applaudît dieu
ouais je peux plus belles histoires
d'amour s'est fait la malle j'imagine
oui sûrement un sur sud fm à seul et
puis tous les autres qui font remarquer
sophie davant evelyne dhéliat marie ange
nardi oui elle est la plus minable
marie-ange larruy vous savez qu'elle
m'appelle belle maintenant
et
quand elle était à la pyramide qu'elle
faisait là mes amis bien sûr vous pouvez
me citer il ya une question sur moi donc
on a dix qui est à jouer le docteur dû
avoir un truc comme ça elle a pas su
répondre quelque et après on l'a dit
mais c'est omar sharif bien sûr elle a
dit mais j'ai jamais entendu parler hall
alors tu vois je
ris mariage est une aventure avec elle
82 marché c'est pas comme sophie davant
bien avoir votre vote
votre plus minables histoire d'amour
tiens on vient depuis la victoire d'un
contrat était avec rita hayworth non oui
c'était j'ai eu une aventure absolument
stupéfiante avec un peu je l'admirais
beaucoup depuis que j'étais très jeune
et un soir elle était elle avait assez
bu et je les raccompagner chez elle
habitait sur les eaux de cannes ont fait
on tournait un film ensemble et moi
j'habitais à nice et quand il est arrivé
il m'a dit ce que vous voulez prendre un
verre
je descends en avait une voiture de la
production avec un chauffeur je vais
avec elle elle avait un bar qui étaient
en bas ne m'a dit vous aimez le vin
blanc j'ai compris que ce qu'elle
voulait que je bois et pris un verre de
vin blanc de verre et puis on a flirté
en la flore tu es très bientôt et puis
au moment où on était au point de haut
point culminant de notre relation elle
me dit mais vous croyez que vous allez
me sauter vous je tiens n'ont jamais
patrick
un jour hamas mais habitués sabic qui
était pas toujours ce qu'ils ont fait
mais comme elle me dit allez sortez vous
êtes vous croyez que vous êtes arrivé
vous avez tourné un film à van holland
d'arabie vous avez laissé jusqu'à oui
mais elle était sous la peau alors matic
bref elle me dit sortez alain je sors et
a pas de la voiture alors je dis mais où
est la voiture mini de renvoyer marché
et jeu et j'ai fait de l'auto-stop à 5
heures du matin que tu es salaam
est-ce que ava gardner la cuve est aussi
un bruit mais elle était adorable
s'était même vraiment mais vraiment ma
copine si vous préférez dans le sexe
les préliminaires et bien là c'était le
cas
je serais content que mes virées avant
de traiter ce qui vous dégoûte le plus
dans le sexe
le l'après sexe quand ça se passe mal 1
quand on se retourne chacun de son côté
contador ou un état fort ou qu'on doive
se rhabiller de partir en afrique a pas
de bagnole
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus